honoring the lives lost on our valley
roads Nevada State Police held a special
event tonight to remember those killed
in 2022 crashes while also reminding
others of the dangers we face every day
good evening to you I'm Brian Loftus and
I'm Denise Valdez Sasha Loftus joins us
live tonight with more on their message
[Music]
tonight one their loved ones on Valley
highways like this last year now they
say they're grateful to see an event
like this happen to honor those killed
while also raising awareness
Enriquez Jose Ruiz honoring the lives
lost on our highways Austin Jacobson
Brady's event at Nevada State Police
offered closure for families like Greg
and Alexandra Johnson the camera visual
I feel is for her their daughter
Katarina was killed in a suspected DUI
crash last September on the us-95 near
Boulder Highway you see all these
families here everyone hasn't has a
victim that's been impacted by this and
it sucks cat is one of
382 people who died on our Nevada roads
in 2022 with 71 Happening Here locally
and this is an opportunity for us to
heal and mourn with our community
members Nevada state trooper Ashley
Wellman says Gatherings like this are
important to help families suffering to
know they're not alone Gregory
while also raising Awareness on the
issues of impaired driving and sharing
more on their mission to keep the worst
from happening that's a human being
That's A Life That's someone's father
son daughter mother and they're no
longer coming home to them the Johnsons
say they're touched to see so much
solidarity for their late daughter a lot
of people come out to support cat I mean
it's completely awesome and they hope
their efforts to speak out prevent these
kinds of tragedies it doesn't matter if
that's one or a hundred it's one too
many
haters who handled these tragedies last
year many including Katz family traveled
from all around the country here to Las
Vegas to attend tonight reporting live
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now